weekly standard founder and Twitter
enthusiast Bill Kristol has helped
launch a venture you've probably never
heard of it's called Hamilton 68 and
it's designed that they claim to combat
Russian disinformation on Twitter but
it's having a bit of a hard time and
seems to be spreading disinformation of
its own for example Hamilton 68 was
behind the claim that the release the
memo campaign to expose fysop abuse by
the FBI wishes to Russian plot with no
support from actual Americans Glenn
Greenwald has been covering this he
writes the intercept he's a critic of
widespread hysteria on this question and
he joins us tonight Glenn I was this is
one of those many stories that fall
through the cracks in a news environment
like this and it's one grateful you have
been on this what is Hamilton 68 him
what is it done so I wrote about it when
it was formed not even a year ago last
summer because it was yet another
example probably the most vivid one yet
this kind of union between Democrats on
the one hand and neo-cons on the other I
guess yes a reunion since neo-cons began
as Democrats and I graded two
Republicans on our network with
Democrats again and it was it's
essentially a group that was as you said
started by people like Bill Kristol
people who have been leading neo cons
from both political parties CIA
officials the people who basically have
been disseminating disinformation
throughout the entire war on terror the
released reliable most war mongering
people in Washington and they said that
their purpose of their group was to
combat disinformation and the attack on
the American democracy by Russia and
other groups and their main kind of
feature was that they would have this
dashboard called Hamilton 68 that
purported to track the activity of
Russian influencers on twitter by
tracking 600 accounts nobody knows which
accounts they've designated as influence
of Russia they're not necessarily
Russian they're just people who in the
eyes of Bill Kristol and his friends are
people who espouse Russia or pro-russia
themes and they just constantly make
claims about
what Russia is doing on Twitter that the
US media in the most
looking way uncritically ingest and puts
into their headlines as fact about what
what what Russia is doing so they're
basically running their own propaganda
campaign purportedly designed to combat
propaganda what's the agenda behind this
I'm a little confused by it there it's
twofold one is these are the people who
have actually been obsessed with the
idea that we should be to war with
Russia for forever back in 2008 when the
president of Georgia attacked two
provinces that view of themselves is
more aligned with Russia and the
Russians went and confronted the
Georgian government about it people like
John McCain and Marco Rubio and that
whole neocon crowd Bill Kristol were
essentially calling for NATO to go to
war with Russia over Georgia
they've been obsessed with Russia
forever and have wanted the
reinvigoration of the new cold war
that's part of it and then the second
part is domestic which is that whatever
views they dislike namely on the left
wing of the party that's
anti-imperialism and anti-war the left
wing in the Democratic Party or the kind
of isolationist paleo conservative wing
or a libertarian wing of the Republican
Party they want to smear as being
aligned with the Kremlin so yes whatever
views are on the right wing of the party
like release the memo or on the left
wing of the party like you know anything
relating to Bernie Sanders
they'll just declare to be a theme of
Russia and then accuse everybody who
advocates at Americans who advocated on
Twitter of being part of a Kremlin
disinformation you and I are on
different sides that we both had that
happen to us so we know firsthand Thank
You Glenn for that I preach